former president Donald Trump's list of
legal problems continues to grow former
employee of his Mar-A-Lago estate Carlos
De Oliveira is making his first court
appearance in Miami
he's accused of working with the former
president to hide security footage from
FBI investigators the Oliveira is in
court nearly two months after Trump
pleaded not guilty to mishandling
classified documents
Rosalind Jordan joins us now from
Washington D.C so how damaging how
serious is this testimony for Donald
Trump
well the allegations are pretty serious
but it all comes down to whether
prosecutors can actually convince a jury
in an eventual trial just how damaging
the actions that Carlos De Oliveira
allegedly carried out were now what is
alleged is that he not only could try to
uh conceal or destroy security camera
footage of the areas at Mar-A-Lago where
these classified documents were
concealed it's also alleged that Mr de
Oliveira lied to Federal investigators
about even knowing about the documents
not meant not to mention his uh actually
helping to move those boxes of
classified documents from one part of
the campus to another those are things
that you simply don't want to do in a
federal investigation and those are part
of the reasons why Federal prosecutors
have brought these charges against Mr
Dale Lavera now for his part because he
doesn't have a local lawyer representing
him all he could do was was basically
agreed to return to court a week from
Thursday he is also out on one hundred
thousand dollars bail and it's there's
the question of whether or not he's
going to have adequate legal
representation because if he doesn't
that could push this trial in this
particular case which is tentatively set
for May of next year it could push that
trial date back again it all comes down
to what kind of evidence prosecutors
actually show the jury when that trial
starts but for right now it does not
look good especially when the suggestion
is that this is an Ever widening
conspiracy
I think so much Rosalind Jordan